اهلا بكم
لو سألت اي developer
ايه الفرق ما بين ان انت تبني software
application او SaaS
application كـMVP و prototype زي ما ال
AI coding tools بتطلع وما بين ان انت
تمشي بال software development life
cycle principle او تبني base محترم
للـapplication اللي انت بتبني ده
او بتحاول تعمله هتلاقي ان فيه فرق كبير
جدا ما بين الحالتين
لو انت مش فاهم ازاي الـ Software Life
Cycle
بتمشي من A to Z
مش هتاخد الـ Quality برضو او الـ
maintainability اللي احنا كـ Software
Developers بنحاول نشوفها و بنحاول نبني
لها بـ beforehand
إنما تلاقي
شركة ما تيجي تقعد تعمل الـdesign
والـrequirements والـplanning في الأول هي بتدي
life cycle للـproject سواء الـ MVP
ده اللي هو في الأول بس
3 شهور مثلا بعد كده تاخد proof of
concept بعد كده تبدأ تطلع في
أو تبدأ تشوف بقى مثلا يعني
الـdesign الـarchitecture اللي هم بنين
وده فعلا
scalable ويقدر الـlong term معاهم يبقى
مزبوط الـmaintainability بتاعته
الـdesign نفسه ما بيقتصرش مثلا على الـ
UI والـ UX
عندك وعندك كامل المفروض هتبقى ماشي به.
آآ جزء بعد كده بقى
اللي هو مثلا احنا بنقول هو دلوقتي مع
لا هو آآ ممكن
بس في حاجات كتيرة او بتبقى فيها وبتأثر
على
و decisions كتيرة بتبقى فعلاً محتاجة
حد فاهم software development
عشان يقدر ياخدها مش معنى ان الـ AI قدر
يطلع لي دلوقتي الـ
MVP اللي أنا كده بدأت
يبقى عندي scalable application أو على
الأقل
maintainable application أقدر أطور فيه
لا بالعكس
لا بس إحنا المفروض كـdevelopers يبقى عندنا
الـ capability أو المقدرة اللي أنا
أقدر فعلاً أوظف الـ
AI coding tools اللي موجودة دي اللي
أنا أبني
بيها فعلاً application يبقى
maintainable ويطلق بـquality كويسة
بس برضو انا مش بحاول اقلل من
الـquality اللي انت ممكن تاخدها فعلا
مع الشغل المظبوط
والـworkflow المظبوط اللي انت ممكن
تعمله مع الـAI agent فانا حابب
يعني ادعو الناس كده اللي احنا مع بعض
نخش نجرب trial ممكن
على مدار اسبوعين او حاجة اللي احنا
نبني SaaS application بنفس
الـworkflow وبنفس الـagentic harness واخد ال
experience من الناس برضو اللي هم
هل ده كده ممكن هم يبقوا راضيين عنه
ويقدروا ان هم يستخدموه في
فعلا اللي
هو المفروض يبقى بني
ويبقى بيفكر فيه مختلف طبعا
عن اي حد برا المجال واللي هو ده فعلا
هيبدأ يوضح
ان ده مش معمول مع او
مش هو اللي بنيه او واخد
المهمة لا بالعكس ده فيه
وفي حد فاهم
الـ Software Development Life Cycle
بتمشي إزاي مظبوط بيطبق الكلام
ده والـ AI بيساعده إن هو يوصل
للـ output بطريقة أسرع بس still
برضو بيبقى aware بالـtechnical debt وبالمشاكل
اللي ممكن تقابله وإزاي إن هو يقدر
يحلها
فلو انت حابب تجاين معنا ونشوف مع بعض
ال experience اللي احنا هناخدها
في استخدام بتاع ان هو يبني
لنا اساس application ونضيف فيه كل
features فعلاً اللي احنا محتاجينها
ونبدأ مع بعض خطوة خطوة من اول ال
installation اللي بتاع نفسه واللي احنا
نعمل install providers نستخدم
اكتر من subscription لو احنا عندنا
subscription ونبدأ
design ونعمل planning مظبوط للاساس
application اللي احنا عايزين نبدأ فيه
ونبدأ فعلاً نشوف
الفرق ما بين الـarchitecture اللي
هتبقى consistent
وهتبدأ تعلق معايا وأقدر اللي أنا
أبني عليها وتبقى maintainable
بالنسبالي وما بين المشاكل اللي معظم
الـvibe-coded applications بتقابلها أن
هي بتوصل لـpoint of time بيبدأ يحصل
degradation للـquality
وللكود اللي حصل منان على أن الـtechnical debt
نفسه بدأ يكبر ويبقى out of hand
فإحنا عندنا هنا بتاع زي ما اتفقنا
totally free هتقدر تعمله ده والـdownload من
هنا أنا أرشح دلوقت اللي أنت تبدأ
بالـElectron application ما عندنا برضو
VS Code extension وـCLI tool بس
التركيز بتاعي الأكتر على
الـdesktop application الكود طبعاً كله
open source
ويحبزها لو حابب يجوين معايا
هنبدأ برضو بالـcommunity أو في
الـBuilders community
موجود عندنا free لحد 25
يوم بمعنى ان اي حد هيجاين معنا هيقدر
ان هو
يأكسس على الـworkshops والكود نفسه
ونبدأ نشرح فتح مبني ازاي
والـfeatures اللي موجودة في كلها
والـSaaS application
المختلف اللي انا بنيته في real estate
ده من اول الـAuthentication والـMulti
tenancy والـDomain Driven Design
والـPayment والـBilling ومن اول
اللي هو الـ Software Development Life
Cycle
اللي احنا متعودين عليها واللي ان معظم
الناس
مش بتشوفها والـ
Vibe-Coded Tools بتخفيها عن الناس ومش
بتظهر بعد فترة ما
يبدأوا بعد سنة وشوية بدأوا فعلاً يحصل
عندهم scaling
وحاجات مشاكل و developer تتغير ومشاكل
كتيرة احنا
قبلناها وبدأنا نحط لها الحلول يعني
اللي انا مركز عليه برضو دلوقتي الـ
TypeScript Stack
ممكن ناس تانية لو
.NET او Python يشتركوا معانا ويبدأوا
يعملوا contribution في ال open source
application نفسه ان هما يضيفوا principle
و best practices ال common اللي
موجودة في ال community بتاع ال .NET
نبدأ نشارك بعض ال experience
ونبني مع بعض
وبرضو معانا ال documentation بتاع ال
application هتبدأ تشرح لك كل الحاجات
اللي انت محتاجها من اول ال requirement
وال download تعمل download ليه بالزبط
احنا هنا عملنا download لل desktop
application هنبدأ اللي احنا نعمله install
مع بعض ممكن زي ما اتفقنا اللي هي
screening window دي تظهر بس زي ما احنا
شايفين كده I'm already registered as a
publisher فال code already
secured فاحنا بس مجرد ما كذا حد يبدأ
يـinstall ال application ده ويبدأ ان هو
verified مش هتظهر الرسالة دي تاني
طبعا وانا بعمل install بتاع انا محتاج
بيبقى عندي طبعا لو انا هستخدم
او انا
عامل او برضو عندنا
وحاجات كتيرة فهي بتبقى معتمدة على
اللي انت مستخدمهم واحنا بننتجريت معاهم
كاوركسترا كا خاصة بالـuser نفسه يعمل
فيها للـharness وحنشوف مع بعض حاجات او
اجزامبل ممكن نشتغل عليه دلوقتي
زي ما احنا شايفين كده اول ما نعمل بتاع
بيفتح معي طبعا بناء على
اللي
انا بستخدمها وانه عندي او
كان متسطب قبل كده فممكن
بتاعكو تختلف شوية تبقى الدنيا فاضية
يعني بس انا طبعا في الاول باجي افتح
هنا اللي انا هبدأ اشتغل به
وبعد كده باجي في الـsettings
هنا وابدأ اضيف الـproviders اللي انا ببدأ
اشتغل معهم ده الـmain provider او ده
اللي هيبدأ
بتاع نفسه يستخدمه
وفيه برضو طريقة تانية اللي انا اقدر
اكونكت بقى مع اللي انت مستخدمها
فمثلا انا عندي الـmain brain بتاعي هو
Claude Code وبقدر ان
انا استخدم الـAntigravity والقلامة
cloud وـCodex
زي ما انا اعرف هنا كده فبقدر ان انا
اشير نفس الـharness ونفس الـsetup اللي
انا بعمله على كل الـproviders
دول بشير الـsetup والحاجات دي ازاي طبعا
لو انا لسه فاتح الـproject من الاول
باجي هنا كده اعمل workspace analysis
لو
ده الـproject موجود عندي ويعني مش حاجة
انا اعمل لها start from scratch
وفيه برضو هنا options تانية هنبقى نقاشها بعدين
اللي هو ازاي انت تبني AI team
builder يعملك حاجة برا اصلا ال
development او برا ال coding
او لو انت عايز تبدأ project جديد بقى
وتعمل scaffold لـSaaS application كل
الحاجات ده هنبدأ نشوفها
معانا في ال builder program بتاعنا
وفيه ال tribunal ده
جميل جدا ويعني انا من الحاجات اللي
بحبها
بالاخص لو انت حد زي عنده كذا provider
او كذا subscription وعايز تستفيد
بيهم فزي ما اتفقنا هنا اول حاجة انا
بحتاج اعملها طالما انا
الـproject موجود عندي لانا اعمل حاجة
اسمها workspace analysis ودي بتبدأ
ترن كده workflow احنا عاملينه ان هو
يشوف او يعمل deep analysis للـproject
يشوف الـtech stack اللي انت مستخدمها
والـframeworks
اللي انت بنى بيها و
design pattern وكل الحاجات دي ويبدأ
بعدها
يبني عليها بقى بناء على ال analysis
اللي هو يعملوه
يبدأ يعمل لي generate للـcoding agent
بتوعي
فيبدأ يعرف لي agents
مثلا في Claude ونفس الكلام لو انا
مستخدم Codex
يبدأ يعرف لي agent برضو اللي فاهمين ال
project بتاعي ل Codex ونفس
برضو هنيجي نتكلم في حاجات تانية شبه ال
connectors و MCP servers
وفي حاجة تانية بقى مثلا
احنا عندنا Memory وـIndexed Memory
وبنعمل AST او tree-sitter
بنبدأ نفهم الكود ونعمل بـGraph Memory
وعندنا برضو RAG system
بحيث يبقى الـcoding agent برضو عنده
طريقة ان هو يأكسس بها الكود
بالاخص لو الـcodebase كبير زي اللي
احنا مستخدمينه ده انا عندي هنا ممكن
Application CLI Tool
دابل React Application Documentation
دابل Astro Application تاني Electron
Application VS Code Extension وعندي
Landing Page والـLicense Server اللي
هو فيها الـCommunity فالـApplication وعندي
Remotion وـVideo Generation Pipeline
كامل
خيال ان كل الـapplications دي
بتشترك مع بعض في نفس الـworkspace
وانا بقدر الـcoding agent بيبقى عارف
المعلومات ان هو عايزها على
كل كوربس من دول برضو في حاجة جميلة او
احنا مقسمين انا اللي احنا عاملين ليه
agent يبدأ يجمع
كمية
خلينا نقول كده memories
لـdomain معين عندنا احنا مشلين بالـdomain
driven design مصبوط فيه طبعا task
management system تقدر تتابع به
الـtasks وتبدأ ال agent
نفس الكلام ليه access على الـtasks
اللي شغالة دي
وده طبعا بقى ال
canvas بتاعنا اللي انا اقدر ارن فيه
كذا session او اقدر اشوف الـsessions
القديمة وكان من الحاجات اللي انا
مهمة بالنسبة لي برضو اللي انا اقدر
اشوف الـextension او سوري الـexecution بتاع
ال AI agent بصورة كويسة
بحيث طبعا لو انت بتبدأ تبني ال harness
بتاعك انت وتبدأ تبني sub agent وعايز
تاخد اقصى استفادة ويبقى هو فعلا فاهم
او تاخد منه output
خليني اقول على الاقل كده المات سينيور
بحيث طبعا اي حد انا متأكد ان اي حد اما
بيجي يعمل سواء
انت ركزت على او مثلا على
ممكن تسكب حتة وممكن تعمل حتة
اللي احنا بنسميه بقى في الاخر اللي هو
فالـtechnical debt ده حاجة اللي انا
مخر منها فلازم انا فاهم انا بعمل ايه ك
عشان الـagents والـorchestration اللي
أنا
ببدأ أستخدمه برضه يبقى على دراية باللي
أنا عارفه وبقى أنا عارف إن مع الوقت
فيه في المنطقة
الفلانية فأنا محتاج محتاج اللي أنا
أحسن فيها أو أعدل فيها
وزي ما إحنا شايفين هنا جزء اللي هو
مثلاً اللي
إحنا اتفقنا عليه أو اللي أنا كلمتوك فيه
اللي أنا بقدر أخلي الـmain agent ده
فهو شغال بـClaude بقدر اخليه اللي هو
يرن مع Codex وممكن
كان الـsession دي كنت خلصت الـCodex
limit بتاعي بقدر اخليه يستخدم Antigravity
والمناسبة هو المخلص الـlimit خليته يرن
نفس الكلام مع
Claude فاعاد يعني ونفس الـsession او
نفس
الـorchestration ده ده احنا عاملينه
كده في layer
غير الـlayer بقى اللي انا ببدأ اتكلم
فيها لان انا ما ابدأ اطلب منه حاجة انا
محتاج اركز اللي انا يبقى هو فاهم مين
الـbusiness
وعارف يدور فين وكده فما بيجي يستخدم هو
الـorchestration بقى ويركو فلو بتبقى
دي حاجة for granted عنده فيقدر يروبوت
الاتنين ببعض ويطلع فعلا output اقدر اللي
انا استخدمه اقدر اللي انا ابني عليه
فلو انتوا حابين فعلاً تشتركوا معايا في
كل اللي موجود ده ونبدأ اللي احنا نشير
ال experience مع بعض ونشوف ازاي ك
software developers نقدر
نطلع software او SaaS application
مختلف عن ان اي حد يقدر يطلعه مع
vibe coded tools ونبقى
فعلاً بنوري السوءة ونوري الناس
والـhype اللي موجود دلوقتي
الدنيا والـsoftware life cycle دي
بتمشي ازاي
بطريقة كويسة انا طبعاً مش بتدعي ان الحاجة
اللي موجودة دي احسن حاجة لا بالعكس
انا متأكد ان اي application بيتبني هو
عمره ما بيوصل
لمرحلة الكمال وعلى طول بيبقى فيه
technical debt ومن
واجبنا احنا كـdevelopers لحنا نوعي
الناس يعني ايه debt
ويعني ايه الـtechnical debt وازاي انه
هو يوظف فلوسه فعلا في
حاجة هتبدأ تفيده ويبدأ انه هو بعد ما
يعمل
MVP وياخد validation بالـprototype
يقدر يسلمه لـsoftware developer كويس
يقدر يبني مش يسكراتش كل اللي حصل ده
ويبدأ تاني من الاول
شكرا